[Music]
this woman is about to attempt something
no human has ever done before dr. Susan
Lockhart is about to be submerged 600
meters beneath the frozen iceberg strewn
Antarctic sea later on in one of the
least explored places
no scientist had been in a submarine in
Antarctica before I didn't think it was
possible
[Music]
vast remote and pristine the Weddell Sea
is one of Earth's last great
wildernesses spanning more than a
million square miles of Antarctic Ocean
and ice it's a refuge for penguins
blue whales and complex underwater
ecosystems but life in the Antarctic is
under threat it's threatened one because
of climate change but in particular
man-made disturbances such as
overfishing
they use such enormous trolls lots of
organisms are killed that aren't the
target species melting ice and improving
fishing technology is rapidly opening up
new areas of the Antarctic Ocean to
fishing there are currently 14 nations
fishing in the Antarctic where there is
fish there is money and where there is
money the fishing will go commercial
fishing will have immediate effects for
the Penguins the seals and the whales
Susan is working with Greenpeace to try
and discover what life exists in the
untouched depths of the Weddell Sea if
she can prove to the Antarctic
Commission a conservation body made up
of 24 member states and the EU that
there are rich and vulnerable ecosystems
she can make a case for creating a
series of marine protected areas zones
in which fishing is restricted or banned
altogether
Susan and her copilot John ho Saba are
on board the dual deep worker mm its
state-of-the-art technology is now
allowing scientists to go where they
have never gone before
we're lifted by a crane and put in the
water you sink down into the depth
water about goes green and gets darker
and darker until there's no light at all
and you're left alone in the dark it's
like going down into an abyss there is
definitely a feeling in space where you
are very tiny being in a very large
ocean
[Music]
to
we got to see things that were glowing
and flashing in the water column on the
way down the sea spiders can be the size
of dinner plates scientists once
believed the seabed here was too cold
too dark and too deep to support much
life
Susan's research paints an entirely
different picture see the sea stars
people are really surprised the colors
on the sea floor of Antarctica are
really spectacular but I think just as
important as the tropical reefs that we
try so hard to protect for Suzan the
next six months are going to be spent in
the lab analyzing her data currently
only 3.7 percent of the world's ocean is
protected but Susan's on a mission to
help make Antarctica the biggest no
fishing zone in the world sponges and
corals are the backbone of community
that can have very low resilience to the
kind of disturbance that fishing here
will cause it would take 10 maybe even
hundreds of years to get back to the
state it was in before the disturbance
so far in her career susan has
identified three-quarters of the
vulnerable marine ecosystems living on
the Antarctic ocean floor but never
before has her research being so
important we need to characterize these
communities as best as we can so that
the evidence that I present to the
Commission later this year is as strong
as possible for the marine protected
area to be established it has to be
unanimously agreed upon by all 24 member
states and the EU approving and passing
the marine protected area proposals is
very difficult
the only other marine protected area in
the Antarctic took ten years of
negotiations the pressure is on there is
definitely a time limit but we can get
it done
many believe transforming the Weddell
Sea into a marine protected area could
be the only way to save its delicate
ecosystems in July 2018 when the
Antarctic commission meets all hopes
will be pinned on Susan and her research
all of us should
about protecting Antarctic because
Antarctica is our responsibility
everyone should watch the negotiations
to make sure that we really are giving
it the best protection because it really
does affect the whole planet for the
next generations
[Music]
[Music]
you